now the plaque has been unveiled in
Iceland to remember the first of its 400
glaciers to be lost to climate change or
kacal glassier used to cover 15 square
kilometres of mountainside now it is
barely one square kilometer and less
than 15 metres deep it was officially
declared dead back in 2014 but now we
have this memorial which bears the
inscription a letter to the Future
warning that all of Iceland's glasses
are expected to disappear in the next
200 years we're talking to us at the
Raymond about this now director of war
on want a global anti-poverty and
climate justice organization he works at
both the UN and with communities most
affected by climate change nice to have
you with us again I said just on this
particular issue it's incredibly
poignant isn't it I read that they've
they've put this plaque here as a letter
to the future and basically said to the
people whoever find it in the future
you'll know whether we succeeded or not
it is an it's an extremely worrying
signing actually should be a letter to
our present because of course this
glacier melting is one of the predicted
outcomes of increasing temperatures and
the reason why the glaciers and
generally ice at the Arctic and the
Antarctic is so important is it reflects
the sun's rays and as the ice melts the
heat is then absorbed into oceans then
triggering more and greater ice melts
and we're seeing this pattern played out
if you look incredibly in the Arctic
Circle as the summer heat wave in Europe
we've had a heat wave also in the Arctic
Circle and we have a hundred current
wildfires being on fire at the moment in
the Arctic Circle and this is really
shocking and devastating news because
this is not predicted to happen in the
timescale it's happening and it's a real
wake-up call hmm and other places too
I've been reading about the Himalayas
how bad is it there well it's absolutely
incredible I mean if you read some of
the reports now it's and I predicted
that 40% of all the glaciers in the
Himalayas will melt now just to put that
into context so the glaciers are very
very important not just in terms of
regulating our environment and
temperature but they're also critical
for human beings
glaciers provide much of the melt or
freshwater and we already saw in India
in the Indian subcontinent this year of
cities running out of fresh water it's
now predicted of the 1.3 billion people
40% of them will will be without access
to fresh water because what we will see
is suddenly the
huge deluge of water as in floods as
there is the glaciers melt and then
sudden dry periods and it will impact on
our food it will course impact as sea
levels increase as the melting ice soars
into the seas we will see a sea level
rise and it's now predicted up to 2
billion people or 1/5 of the world's
population will be displaced from their
homes many of them of course with
nowhere to go and this is a reality
that's happening it's about 1.1 degree
of warming and scientists tell us that
once we reach the 1.5 these kind of
trigger points will become inevitable
and they will just start to speed up
can't be reversing and the shocking news
of course is that we're on we're on a
trajectory that will that will lead us
to at least 3 and maybe even up to 7
degrees warming one thing though I said
and and this is as much responsibility
of us and the media as well as that I
think the discussion around climate
change has changed it is being reported
a lot more it's being reported as an as
a current issue as an emergency issue in
many places as well do you think the
importance is getting through to people
now well I think there has been a
definitely a sea change in in how the
media reports and I think there's a
recognition that climate change is of
course an extremely serious issue it's
not an environment issue in the sense of
it's something abstract from people it's
our it will affect every person on this
planet one way or another but I don't
think we've really got through to real
other policymakers I think the
policymakers are still think that we can
continue to business as usual and tweak
around the edges and something will
happen that will prevent the worst
impacts of climate change and I think
the evidence as we see around the world
of killer floods droughts famines Shores
that that's not happening actually these
impacts are happening now unfortunately
most of those and impacts happened to
the poorest people
the ones were the least responsible so I
don't think that the country's most
responsible for the economic powerhouses
of the world that are most responsible
are the ones that really serious at this
moment about trying to make the drastic
changes the positive news and I think
increasingly we're seeing this with
ordinary people recognizing that by
tackling climate change we can also
tackle many of the world's problems I
just heard your piece earlier about
Mexico and your air pollution weather we
talked about the fact that you know half
the world's population live on less than
$5 a day or you know a third of the
world still suffers from food issues we
can solve all of those by having good
policies on guaranteeing the right to
food and and fixing our broken economic
system so actually all of us can have a
dignified life or we can actually live
in a much cleaner fairer in a better
world the problem of course is there are
large powerful corporations by making a
hell of a lot of me a moment from the
fossil fuel economy and from our food
industry who don't want to change and
until we as ordinary citizens are
mandating our politicians and political
leaders to act with more urgency I think
it could be too little too late dear
always great to talk to you though I
said thank you I said back on joining us
sir today from Portugal